et pour commencer ce journal une
information politique samedi dernier la
section jeunes udi des yvelines a élu
son nouveau président tout l'après midi
jusqu'à 18 heures les adhérents étaient
invités à venir voter
une seule liste était proposé à 28 ans
et marc lerouge qui est donc devenu le
président des jeunes du diy vinoy
commercial de profession il est entré à
l'idée en 2013
marc lerouge est actuellement élu au
développement économique à l'emploi et
au transport aux clayes-sous-bois ville
u10 sa priorité être plus présents sur
le terrain et se faire connaître auprès
de la population écoute élus l'étaient
au micro de camille lambert
on va écouter parler les gens on va leur
poser des questions on va les écouter
et puis on va on va faire connaître nos
idées centristes et essayer de
s'enrichir aussi de toutes ces
rencontres qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
vous avez beaucoup de jeunes qu'ils
soient dans les yvelines ou ailleurs qui
qui se tournent vers le front national
on a dans les yvelines la seule ville
front national des d'île de france
donc nous on veut passer un message un
message beaucoup plus positif un message
qui parle de république d'europe
d'espoir et pas du tout un message
mortifère com est aujourd'hui envoyées
par le fn un petit peu partout